mr. Richard Gere
yeah yeah hi just wanted to remind you
again what this meant here this red
ribbon is in sympathy of AIDS victims
all over the world and since this is
going to countries all over the world I
think an appropriate thing to think
about is what can you do about it which
is in these day and age when whens
defense budgets are shrinking we can
take some of that defense money and put
it into AIDS research I think we do it
in our own country so you can actually
call and write to congressman and
Senator and they do listen if they get
that note from you so please send it
films can be made without scripts sets
directors special effects or the man who
makes the coffee a movie can even be
made without actors but so far no one
can make one without cinematographers
tonight I'd like to dedicate the Award
for cinematography to the memory of
Nestor almond rose
Lester is quite an extraordinary man and
in DP one of the great ones in the
history of cinema he he his first
American film was in 1978 I think it was
a 79 and he won an Oscar for that film
which is also my first film Days of
Heaven on France same wasallam GCL now
the nominees for cinematography are Alan
Davey Oh for Bugsy Robert Richardson the
JFK Stephen Goldblatt for Prince of
tides hi Stevie Adam greenberg for
Terminator 2 Judgment Day and Adrian
Biddle for Velma and Louise and the
Oscar goes to very exciting Robert
Richardson for JFK
all right the Academy wants to
congratulate Robert Richardson and I
will accept it on his behalf he's not
here tonight thank you very much